[Música]
muchas voces unidas en un mismo pedido
afuera caixayet
miles se reunieron en la capital de
túnez para mostrar su descontento con el
actual mandatario
esta manifestación es para expresar una
vez más nuestro rechazo a las medidas
políticas anunciadas por caixayet y las
próximas elecciones que solo
fortalecerán la tiranía y la dictadura
en el país
uno de los mayores días de protesta que
denunciaba la toma del poder por parte
de sayet el año pasado que pasó a
gobernar por decreto después del cierre
del parlamento y tiempo después aumentó
sus poderes con la instauración de una
nueva constitución
para muchos se trata de un retroceso en
la lucha hacia la democracia que
encontró su punto más álgido en 2011
cuando después de enormes protestas se
derrocó al régimen autocrático de cine
y desencadenó la denominada como
Primavera
el pueblo tunecino que luchó durante 50
años por la democracia no permitirá que
el golpe de estado sea asiento en este
país y ha visto el alcance de la mala
gestión la incompetencia y el fracaso
[Aplausos]
el descontento en túnez va en aumento la
falta de productos básicos como el
aceite vegetal el azúcar y el arroz y el
aumento del costo del agua ha
desencadenado en un gran malestar
colectivo
voy a defender a mi país y a defender
nuestros derechos tú nos está sangrando
el hambre y la pobreza ya no tenemos
nada túnez
mientras la oposición al gobierno parece
estar más unida que nunca sayet denuncia
que intentos dentro del país de socavar
la independencia